Hey guys, it's Joel with the Tabaret Therapy Collective podcast. And if you're wondering, why is this episode here? Why did God give me this episode? It serves no purpose and is only a source of infection that might have to be removed, but shouldn't exist. It's because this is an appendix to the Making Meaning in the Modern World or Healing the Modern Soul series that I've been doing. And I basically did that series because there's a bigger series about the whole history of psychology.
大家好，我是Tabaret Therapy Collective播客的Joel。如果你在想，为什么会有这一集？上帝为什么要给我这一集？它毫无用处，甚至只是一个可能需要被切除的感染源，本不该存在。这是因为这一集是我一直在做的《在现代世界中寻找意义》或《治愈现代灵魂》系列的附录。我做那个系列主要是因为有一个关于心理学整个历史的更大系列。
But with psychology itself as kind of the character, not like a boring, dry textbook, but this thing adapting and changing. If I ever finish that series that I have copious notes for, I think it'll be like my magnum opus that I like have wanted to make for a super long time. It'll be really involved. Um, it'll be like some of the bigger, uh, audio, uh, you know, podcast multi-part mini series event things that I like, uh, but about my interests and I don't have any time to do it. And so I just decided that I was going to read through sort of the rough notes and talk about it. And this was sort of a rough draft of that. So what I was going to do in the appendix is just go through all the notes that I essentially didn't get to and clarify some of the points that it would have slowed down the series to dig into in a more specific way, when a lot of that was about not being specific,
但那个系列是以心理学本身作为主角，而不是像枯燥乏味的教科书，而是一个不断适应和变化的事物。如果我能完成那个我有大量笔记的系列，我想那将是我一直以来梦寐以求的代表作。它会非常复杂。嗯，它会像我喜欢的一些大型音频、播客多部分迷你系列活动那样，但内容是关于我的兴趣，而我没有时间去做。所以我决定把那些粗略的笔记读一遍并谈谈。这算是那个系列的草稿。所以我在附录里要做的是，把那些我基本上没来得及讲的笔记过一遍，并澄清一些如果深入探讨会拖慢整个系列节奏的观点，尽管那个系列很大程度上就是为了不那么具体。
was about being kind of poetic as a point. And so I didn't want to get in the way of myself with that. If you haven't listened to the Making Meaning of the Modern World series, this episode probably makes little to no sense and isn't something that you want to listen to. If you listen to the Making Meaning or Healing the Modern Soul series and was like, I don't like this, or I don't get it, this isn't what we're normally doing, you probably don't want to listen to if you listen to the making meaning or healing the modern soul series and was like i don't like this or this isn't i don't get it this is what we're normally doing you probably don't want to listen to the appendix um but i'm just going to go through basically the notes that
重点在于某种诗意。所以我不想在这方面阻碍自己。如果你没有听过《在现代世界中寻找意义》系列，这一集可能没什么意义，也不值得你听。如果你听了《在现代世界中寻找意义》或《治愈现代灵魂》系列，觉得“我不喜欢这个”或者“我不明白，这和我们平时做的不一样”，那你可能不想听这个附录。嗯，但我只是打算过一遍那些基本上没讲完的笔记。
were left um that i didn't get to go through uh in their entirety but we got a lot into a philosophy in that for the first time in a bit and i basically like i don't like philosophy very much like i'm not a philosophy guy. I don't have anything against it. I like some of it, but I think the overall, especially, like, academic philosophy trend in my lifetime has been kind of like, I don't know, it's just not for me. And part of that is I think that a lot of the values that I have
那些我没能完整讲完的笔记。我们在那个系列中第一次深入探讨了哲学，但我基本上不太喜欢哲学，我不是那种搞哲学的人。我并不反对它。我喜欢其中的一部分，但我认为在我有生之年，尤其是学术哲学的整体趋势，怎么说呢，就是不太适合我。部分原因是我认为我所持有的许多价值观——
for how we should communicate and what the point of, like, intuition and soul and life and self and all that is, is explained to me better by people fighting about psychotherapy than people fighting about philosophy. Because what happens in philosophy a ton of the time from where I'm sitting is that you have people that basically like make up a bunch of definitions for things and then say, well, if these suppositions are all true then here's all these like little logical games that we can play with them so that i can go get get like into law school and i i just uh i don't get it like that isn't something that i want to do
关于我们应该如何沟通，关于直觉、灵魂、生命、自我等等的意义，比起那些争论哲学的人，那些争论心理治疗的人能更好地向我解释。因为在我看来，哲学中经常发生的情况是，人们基本上编造了一堆定义，然后说：“好吧，如果这些假设都是真的，那么这里有所有这些我们可以玩的小逻辑游戏，这样我就可以去上法学院了。”我只是……我不明白，那不是我想做的事情。
then you have people that i do like um like nietzsche and wittgenstein and you know there's a there's a lot of humanistic and feeling-driven philosophy to Schopenhauer and people like that, and that's fine, but they usually sort of speak for themselves and stand for themselves, and it's not something that occupies a ton of academic philosophy's time because they're either Plato and Nietzsche, so vague that the point is kind of like a poetic, noetic experience. And, you know, people can say, well, I like it, but they don't really get it.
然后有一些我确实喜欢的人，比如尼采和维特根斯坦，你知道，叔本华和类似的人的哲学中有很多充满人文关怀和情感驱动的内容，这很好，但他们通常是为自己代言，代表自己，这并不是学术哲学占据大量时间的内容，因为他们要么像柏拉图和尼采那样，模糊到重点在于一种诗意的、心灵的体验。而且，你知道，人们可以说“我喜欢它”，但他们并不真正理解它。
But there's not a lot of specificity to fight about. And then what sucks up like all of the time is like analytical philosophy where people make all these suppositions and are like, oh, but Diogenes made like the seven step proofs for forms against forms and that's the most complicated proof in all of classical philosophy because he says you know if forms exist then they might be this but then there are differences i don't care like i just um that stuff is uh not anything that i ever really want to get into on here it's just not the kind of uh thing that i devote my brain power to is the seven step proof of diogenes and all the stuff that i uh a lot of um you know
但没有什么具体的东西可以争论。然后，占据所有时间的是分析哲学，人们做出所有这些假设，然后说：“哦，但是第欧根尼针对形式做出了七步证明，这是所有古典哲学中最复杂的证明，因为他说，你知道，如果形式存在，那么它们可能是这样，但随后又存在差异……”我不在乎，我只是……那些东西不是我在这里想深入探讨的，我不会把脑力花在第欧根尼的七步证明以及很多哲学家真正喜欢的东西上。
philosophers really like um something like this the schwep podcast that goes through um a lot of like classical philosophy in context and and going through its perspectives that's the way that i want to approach classical philosophy and so that's um to me you know like a branch of psychology not um yeah just like a system of arguments that i think is like turning philosophy into debate club is like kind of retrojective and that like people were making these arguments but that wasn't the point of what they were doing and then we've sort of made that the only point of it because we can diagram them in the same way that like diagramming a sentence and looking at grammar is not the point of like talking I don't think that diagramming logical arguments is
像《Schwep》播客那样，在语境中梳理大量古典哲学并探讨其视角，那才是我想要接近古典哲学的方式。所以对我来说，你知道，那是心理学的一个分支，而不是仅仅像一套论点系统。我认为把哲学变成辩论俱乐部是某种倒退，因为人们当时提出这些论点并不是他们做这些事情的初衷，而我们却把它变成了唯一的重点，因为我们可以像分析句子和研究语法那样去图解它们，但我认为图解逻辑论点根本不是柏拉图的重点。
the point of Plato at all so you know what I am looking for like what I'm writing about on here like what I see is the point of you know because it heals trauma essentially and a lot's why a lot of writers and artists are very traumatized is people that are able to use their intuition to see the future I mean that's the thing that I talk about the most when we did the series with Leon Krier, when we did like me talking about the Eames and their development of basically like furniture and culture until they're preempting this feeling, you know, they knew the internet was coming even though they didn't know what it was in this way that I think is purely a psychological, you know, probably material phenomenon, but it's pretty incredible. It feels spiritual. Spiritual language applies to it. And the spiritual metaphysical language might be right. Again, I'm a psychotherapist,
所以我在这里写的是什么，我所看到的重点是什么，因为这本质上治愈了创伤，这也是为什么很多作家和艺术家深受创伤的原因，他们是那些能够利用直觉预见未来的人。我的意思是，这是我在与Leon Krier合作系列时谈论最多的事情，当我们谈论伊姆斯夫妇（Eames）以及他们对家具和文化的开发，直到他们预见到这种感觉时，你知道，他们知道互联网即将到来，尽管他们不知道它会以这种方式出现，我认为这纯粹是一个心理学上的，你知道，可能是物质现象，但这太不可思议了。它感觉很灵性。灵性的语言适用于它。而灵性的形而上学语言可能是对的。再说一次，我是心理治疗师，
not a priest. I don't really pick a side. I just think it's neat. I don't know. I don't think I can know. And so what I'm doing is like looking at people like Philip K. Dick, like, you know, when we talked to Andres Duany, a billion other artists that I really like, but that's sort of all of what they're doing. And that was the point of the series on philosophy was to look at people that were sort of saying something that they didn't think would be seen for a really long time or they didn't think would be understood or something that they couldn't say, you know, all of that messy stuff um but that whole kind of like one of my um like the most grating things for me is people that think like the debate club thing is productive in therapy like the people the therapists who like debate patients who like try and like make an argument and are like well if i'm not using logical points to refute their beliefs, then how would they ever change? I don't know. Have you ever seen one of your patients change? Like when you get
不是牧师。我真的不选边站。我只是觉得这很有趣。我不知道。我不认为我能知道。所以我所做的是观察像菲利普·K·迪克（Philip K. Dick）这样的人，就像我们和安德烈斯·杜阿尼（Andres Duany）谈话时提到的，还有其他十亿个我真正喜欢的艺术家，但这基本上就是他们所做的一切。这就是哲学系列的目的，去观察那些说了一些他们认为很久都不会被看到，或者他们认为不会被理解，或者他们无法说出的东西的人，你知道，所有那些混乱的东西。但那种……对我来说最令人恼火的事情之一是，那些认为辩论俱乐部在治疗中是有成效的人，那些试图与病人辩论的治疗师，他们试图提出论点，并说：“好吧，如果我不使用逻辑点来反驳他们的信念，他们怎么会改变呢？”我不知道。你见过你的病人改变吗？就像当你深入到大脑制造逻辑的部分之下时，当你深入到那之下并处理那些助长这种理智化或加倍坚持这些信念的情绪时，那才是人们改变的时候。你可以说：“好吧，辩论俱乐部很重要，因为你去法学院时必须图解这些证明。”我的意思是，是的，你可能需要学习古典哲学才能进入法学院，或者你需要理解经验论证的本质，即你必须就术语达成一致，然后进入某种……是的，但这并不难。它肯定不像很多人说的那样难。一旦你……我知道很多律师，一旦你毕业并真正从事法律工作，那些都不重要了。你所做的是回到我认为的重点，那就是讲一个故事。你知道，法学院会告诉你，事实并不重要。你需要知道法律是如何应用的以及它的假设是什么。但当你面对12个你需要说服的人时，你所做的……而且法律有很多种。我知道我谈论的是电影里的刑法，但当你必须这样做时，事实并不重要。你所做的是讲一个故事。
underneath the logic making part of the brain, like when you get underneath that and you deal with the emotion that is fueling the need to be that intellectual or to double down on these beliefs, that's when people change. And like you can say, you know, well, debate club so important, because you have to diagram these proofs when you go to law school. I mean, yeah, you have to maybe take classical philosophy to get into law school or two, you need to understand the nature of empirical argument that you have to agree on terms and then go into something like, yeah, but that isn't that hard. It certainly isn't as hard as like a lot of people make it. And as soon as you, you know, I know a lot of people that are lawyers, like as soon as you graduate and you're
这在某种程度上是我对治疗的简单看法。很多人无法看到并接受这一点，这是不成熟的表现，也是无法接受你不会以这种方式被赋能，或者世界从根本上是不公平的，或者你知道，你实际上无法按照你的条件得到你想要的东西，如果你想得到它，你必须放弃你的条件。这就是治疗中让我感兴趣的地方，也是我在这个系列中谈论的内容。你可以成为那种说“这不公平”的人。
actually doing law, none of that matters. What you're doing is going back to what I think the point is, which is to tell a story. You know, the, the, the thing that they'll tell you in law school is like, the facts don't really matter. You need to know how the law is applied and what the assumptions of it are. But when you're dealing with 12 people that you have to convince of something, what you, and there's a lot of kinds of law. Like I know that I'm talking about, you know, movie criminal law, but like when you have to do that, the facts don't matter. What you're doing is telling a story.
每个人都应该合乎逻辑，如果每个人都做预算，那么就不需要政府监管，因为人们只需通过购买决策就能让巨大的多层垄断企业负责。猜猜怎么着？人们不是那样工作的。你说你希望一切都成为辩论俱乐部，你希望治疗、政治或哲学成为那样，或者任何其他东西，那是因为你无法接受人们不是那样，他们不那样思考，而且永远不会。好吧，所以这是你需要克服的问题，我们实际上不会通过坐在那里说“没有真正的苏格兰人，归谬法，人身攻击”来解决问题。有一个政党在每次选举中都试图推选一位候选人，他说：“好吧，我只是要出去做一个极其经验有效的论点，并告诉人们去我网站的第500页。”他们总是输。因为无论你认为人们是否应该按照人们被编程的方式行事，他们就是那样被编程的。无论你是否想
And that is sort of what I think about therapy in a simplistic way. There's a lot of inability to see that and accept that is immaturity um and the inability to you know accept that you're not going to be enabled in this way or that the world fundamentally isn't fair or that you know like you can't actually have the thing that you want on your terms you have to let go of your terms if you're going to get it. That's what interests me about therapy, and that's sort of what I'm talking about in this series. And you can be one of those people that's like, well, that isn't fair.
接受大脑的工作方式，它仍然按照它的方式工作。而且，你知道，这其中的讽刺、张力和趣味性在于，那些本质上研究哲学和心理学中的思想、自我的人，甚至无法接受他们自己和他人的思想的术语来做好这件事。我看到，你知道，基本上自我被研究得更好。你知道，是的，每一百年，也许你会遇到一个哲学界的人，但我通常看到，我从没想过我会这么说，我看到它被学术心理学研究得比被学术哲学研究得更好。所以我只是不太深入研究它。我认为它在这里相关的原因是因为我们想处理那些每百年出现一次的哲学家，我认为他们做了一些
Everyone should be logical, and if everyone just did a budget, then there would be no need for government regulation because people could hold giant multi-level monopol know monopolies accountable just with their purchasing decisions guess what people don't work that way like you saying that you want everything to be debate club that you want therapy to be that or politics to be that or philosophy to be that or whatever like that is your inability to accept that people are not that they don't think that way and they never will okay so that's your thing to get over, that we're not actually going to solve problems by sitting there being like,
相当不可思议的事情，因为他们看穿了过去200年、100年的世界，以一种无人能懂的方式预见了下一个100年。尼采是总是因此获得赞誉的大人物，因为他以一种相当直白的方式写到它。他就像让一个疯子进来，说：“嘿，你们不了解你们所处的新世界。”人们说：“哈哈，你不了解它，因为你有没有想过我们还看不到它，也不会接受它？”他说：“好吧。”他并不是真正的疯子，你知道，他有点
no true Scotsman, ad absurdum, ad hominem. There's a political party that has tried every other election to run a candidate who says, well, I'm just going to go out and make an incredibly empirically valid argument and tell people to go to page 500 of my website and they always lose. Because whether or not you think people should behave the way that people are programmed, they are programmed the way they're programmed. Whether or not you want to
像是在给整个社会一个暗讽，或者至少是他写作的那个时代。所以，是的，有这些伟大的哲学家很有趣，但我最终谈论斯洛特戴克（Sloterdijk）的原因，尽管我对他了解不多，我可能没有足够的装备去理解我读过或听他说过的所有东西，而且英语中关于他的东西也不多，这也是我认为这些大语言模型之类的东西很好的原因之一，因为你可以真正获得你无法以其他方式获得的翻译。我不是硅谷那一套的忠实粉丝，但是的，利用它能做的事情。但我认为他如此不同的原因之一是，
accept the way the brain works, it still works the way that it works. And, you know, part of the irony and the tension and the funniness of this is people who are studying essentially like the mind, the self in philosophy and psychology won't accept the terms of their own and other people's minds enough to do it well. And I see, you know, basically self being studied better. You know, yeah, every hundred years, maybe you get somebody in philosophy, but generally by academic, never thought I'd say this, I see it being studied better by academic psychology than I see it studied by academic, never thought I'd say this, I see it being studied better by academic psychology than I see it studied by academic philosophy. So it's just like not a thing that I really dig into a ton. The reason why I think it's relevant here is because we wanted to deal with some of those philosophers who come out every hundred years and I think do something
现在其他所有在瞎搞的人，要么变得极其后现代，自称后后现代，假装与众不同，但他们其实不然。你知道，齐泽克（Zizek）在任何重要方面与拉康（Lacan）并没有太大区别。是的，我知道他们的信仰，
that's pretty incredible because they see through the last 200, 100 years of the world to anticipate the next hundred in a way that no one understands. Nietzsche's like the big figure that always gets credit for this because he's writing about it in a pretty on-the-nose way. He's like having a madman come in and say, hey, you know, y'all don't understand the new world that you're in. And people are like, ha ha ha, you don't understand it because have you thought about how we can't see it and won't accept it yet and he's like okay and he's not really the mad one you know and he's sort
以及他们不同意对方，他们提出了不同的观点，但他们仍然是同一运动的一部分，试图不成为该运动的一部分。或者有一些人在那里反对后现代主义，说：“实际上，我们应该回去，因为我想把所有这些东西倒推，并在历史中看到另一个叙事。”你知道，乔丹·彼得森（Jordan Peterson）现在决定他是一位哲学家，
of like uh Nietzsche's sort of like giving an underhanded compliment to all of society always um or at least you know the time that he's writing in um so yeah like there are these these big um philosophers that are interesting but the reason why i ended talking about slaughter duke even though i don't know a ton about him i'm probably not terribly well equipped enough to understand everything by him that i've read or heard him say um which there's not a ton of it in english either uh which is that's one of the reasons why i think these large language models and stuff is so nice as you can actually get translations of things that you couldn't otherwise get I'm not a huge fan of the Silicon Valley stuff but yeah use it for what it can do but one of the reasons why I
你知道，可能是因为他失去了执照。这是人们常做的事情，你知道，当你失去工作时，你不会说“哦，哎呀”，你会说“哦，我现在是哲学家了”。你知道，“我失业了转行做哲学家”是一条走惯了的路，所以祝你好运。但是，你知道，像他这样的人会提出这种论点，即我们真的需要回到过去，如果你看看所有事物的第一原则，那么它们都证明了这些他想让你思考的事情，但我认为它们并没有。你知道，你会说笛卡尔与亚里士多德是统一的，因为笛卡尔面对怀疑的巨人，说：“我不知道我的任何假设是真的，我唯一能信任的就是我自己。”所以这与亚里士多德在概念化知识来自我正在思考的形式时所看到的与神圣的联系是同一回事吗？好吧，是的，我不知道。心理学101，伙计，有时候简化并不是完全错误的。笛卡尔对知识的看法与亚里士多德有着根本的不同。它们是不一样的。你不能真正把那个圆圈画成正方形。你可以谈论很长时间，直到它们在一个循环中重新结合。但这往往是他试图说服自己相信某事。我不是要针对彼得森，我只是说有很多这样的人，Vervecki或者其他什么人，还有另一个像YouTube博主的人，我真的不喜欢生活在
think he's so different is that like everyone else who's kind of mucking around right now is like either being incredibly postmodern and calling themselves post-postmodern and pretending to be different, but they're really not. You know, like Z-Tech is not terribly different from Lacan in any way that is important. Like, yes, I know what they believe
那个世界，但我看到的这两种运动是：后现代主义假装不是后现代主义，我想后现代主义会很擅长这样做，或者解构的工具将对你很有用，让你假装你不是你所属的运动的一部分，该运动是不可分割成一百万部分的；然后是人们说“我不喜欢那样，别那样做”。像斯洛特戴克这样的人不是，他是唯一的人之一，我再说一遍，我不喜欢这家伙，我对他一无所知，你甚至无法获得他写的大部分东西，除了《球体》三部曲和《批判》以及其他几样东西，但……而且，你知道，他说的有些话也是疯狂和法西斯的，我不是在为这个人辩护，海德格尔也是纳粹，对吧？这些东西有一半是建立在追踪“此在”（Dasein）以及那些与时间和本体论本质的联系之上的。但是，斯洛特戴克与众不同的地方，我以他结尾的原因是，我不认为他在做和其他人一样的事情。这还不是很明显。如果会有这个新阶段，如果会有这个具有预见性的新事物，那很可能就是像他这样的人。他是那个开始看穿其他人正在争论的事情的人。而这个系列的大部分本质，
and that they don't agree and that they're making different points, but they're still part of the same movement trying not to be. Or there's people out there like fighting against postmodernism and saying, actually, we should go back because I want to retroject all this stuff and see another narrative into the history of whatever. You know, Jordan Peterson has now decided he's a philosopher,
如果你从中学到任何东西，那就是对话和治疗，是那里的自我本质与他们周围世界的关系之间的对话。当那个世界像我们的世界变化得这么快时，我们必须……我们看到的可能不是本质。再说一次，我不想成为哲学家。
you know, probably because he lost his license. And it's a popular thing that people do, you know, like when you lose your job, instead of saying like, oh, oops, you say, oh, I'm a philosopher now. You know, the I lost my job to philosopher pipeline is a well-worn pathway, so good luck. But, you know, people like him will make this argument that we really need to just go back in time and that like if you look at the first principles of everything, then they all justify these things that he wants you to think in a way that I don't think they do. You know, like you'll say that Descartes is united with Aristotle because Descartes is facing the giants in doubt of saying, I don't know any of my assumptions are true and the only one I can
也许人类自我的本质并没有改变那么多，但人类自我的现实却改变了不少，因为周围的世界太不同了。就像我刚才在第四部分带你从七十年代走到2000年代中期，解释了为什么这些力量如此改变了心理治疗，因为人们带入治疗的东西在60年代根本不存在，比如当时不存在的生活观念。你不能再做弗洛伊德了。你必须开始制造这些其他东西。很多猜测是错误的。很多猜测是对其他事物的过度反应。我正在用我的治疗做这件事。我正在用我的系列做这件事。没有人是例外。我不是先知。我不知道。我倾向于认为给病人更多的现实控制权更安全，而且在你的方法中更具整合性也更安全，这样当你试图理解病人所居住的世界中的自我时，你会更灵活。我曾在治疗中受过伤，就像我谈到的那个疯狂且无能的家伙，我有点嘲笑它，因为它太疯狂了，但我因此患上了创伤后应激障碍（PTSD），你知道，我不得不去看另一个治疗师。如果发生了这样的事情，我不会掉以轻心。而且当它发生在我身上时非常痛苦。我不是来谈论那个的，但你知道，这些东西很重要，我看到心理治疗比许多其他基本上谈论自我和生活的学科更具治疗性。我喜欢人类学。我喜欢社会学。我喜欢哲学，但我只是不在那些水域里游泳。你知道，也许荣格的东西让我与人类学、自我和哲学进行了对话。但彼得森正在做的一件没有帮助的事情，以及很多这些新人正在做的事情，仅仅是因为它能卖品牌，能让人们在YouTube上留下评论，比如“哇，我不够聪明，听不懂这些词，但我足够聪明，知道这是有史以来最聪明的东西。这家伙是对的。”然后就像是，好吧，嗯，是的，事情不是那样运作的。但是，彼得森正在做的是对卡尔·荣格的非常浅层的解读，以及对米尔恰·伊利亚德（Mircea Eliade）的非常浅层的解读，
trust is myself. And so that is dealing with the same connection to the divine that Aristotle sees when he conceptualizes knowledge coming from the form that I'm thinking about? Well, yeah, I don't know. Psychology 101, man, like sometimes it's not terribly wrong to reduce. Like Descartes believes a pretty fundamentally different thing about knowledge than Aristotle. They're not the same. You can't really square that circle. You can talk for a long time until they come back together in a loop. But that tends to be him trying to convince himself of something. and I'm not meaning to pick on Peterson like I'm just saying that there's a lot of people doing that Vervecki or something there's another guy that's like a YouTube guy I don't really like live in
他声称所有的宗教都在说同样的事情。然后，如果你进去，把希伯来圣经中的每一个细节，或者塔木德（Talmud）或任何实际上是在嘲笑巴比伦或嘲笑罗马帝国并说那些东西是坏的，并且它们会通过某种方式调整它们的神话而被摧毁的东西都削掉……如果你只是把所有这些都拿走，那么在它之下，真的，所有的宗教都是一样的，
that world but those are the kind of the two movements I see is like post-modernism pretending not to be post-modernism which I guess post-modernism is going to be like good at doing or the tools of deconstruction are going to be useful for you to pretend that you're not a part of the movement that you're a part of that has is indivisible into you know indivisible into a million parts and then people saying i don't like that don't do that um somebody like slaughter deke is not he's like one of the only people and i again like i don't love the guy i don't know anything about him you can't even get anything that he's written largely other than like the spheres trilogy and critique and a couple other things but like um and you know then there's things that
它们只是有相同的神话，它们只是有相同的原型。我的意思是，我喜欢荣格的东西，原型是存在的，但要把文化中的一切都以那种还原论的方式分开，就像说“我们可以用荣格来向我们展示笛卡尔原则，我们可以用这种荣格的方式，它是笛卡尔式的，来向我们展示所有这些存在于每个神话中的东西”。所以它们就像我们必须遵循的第一原则。我的意思是，很明显他在那样做。不是因为那是一种帮助任何人、寻找知识或寻找新事物的有趣方式，而是因为他相信一堆他想让你相信的东西。他在智力上在泥潭里打转，试图想出一种方法，你知道，尼采正在批判的同一件事，去说“我希望你拥有的我的信念，我对此如此情绪化，并迫切需要成为你的现实，也需要成为真实的，我已经用理性证明了它是真实的”，我认为这是一种危险的做法，因为理性、逻辑和所有那些辩论俱乐部式的哲学东西，我只是觉得很愚蠢。我的意思是，像维特根斯坦这样的人可能正在等待像现在这样的时代。他非常出名地说：“我不太喜欢那些喜欢我的人，我是在为后代写作。”如果你玩过《刺客信条》，第一部，很久以前，或者可能是第二部或第三部，但它是早期的作品之一。在育碧把它变成《刺客信条》宇宙之前。
he says that are insane and fascist too like i'm not defending the person the thing the reason that i and heidegger is a nazi too right like half of this stuff is built on following up on dasein and those, you know, connections with time and the nature of ontology. Um, but the thing that is different about Slaughter Deke, the reason that I ended with him is I don't think he's doing the same thing that everyone else is. And that's not really apparent yet. Like if there is going to be this new phase, if there is going to be this new thing that is anticipatory, it probably is going to be somebody like him. He's the one that's starting to see past the things that everyone else is fighting about. And just the nature of so much of this series,
有一个地方，过去角色的记忆被未来的角色读取，他已经死了几千年了。还有一个场景像《沙丘》（Dune），如果我引用了《沙丘》，那可能更像是一个受过教育的“我有很多季节的书”类型的人设，但这并不重要。那个角色就像……我不明白，在过去，那个角色就像……他的思想被未来的角色读取，就像“我不明白你为什么要告诉我这个”，那个人就像“因为我不是在和你说话，我是在通过你说话”，他们就像“是的，但为什么？”他们就像“安静，记住这个，因为有人会在2000年后读取你的大脑”，或者没那么久……别来找我，我也不是搞历史的，别来找我。但维特根斯坦会说：“我是在为这个时代之后的一个时代写作。”而且，也许阅读他的一个非常好的方法是读他好像在说……而且他改变了很多，人们对此争论不休。
like if you take anything, get the conversation and therapy, is a conversation between the nature of the self there and their relationship to the world around them. And when that world is changing as fast as our world is changing, then we have to, we're going to see not the nature maybe. And again, I don't want to be a philosopher.
我不是说我知道如何解释这些东西。我不专门研究它。这些是三手的、业余的、愚蠢的印象，希望你作为对治疗进展感兴趣的人，或者治疗师，或者治疗中的病人，希望两者都是，可以像“哦，我会把它应用到我的治疗技术中，以及那种业余的、有趣的、文科的、我不太明白，但我想玩弄它的方式，我认为治疗应该这样做。”而且治疗师一直以来都是这样做的。关于他谈论的学科有很多，而且当他把它们放在一起时，他说了很多更疯狂的话，被那些在这些领域、专门研究这些个体领域的人所否定。所以是的，知道很多东西并不总是真的有帮助。但像维特根斯坦所说，他基本上是在为这个尚未到来的时代写作，他是在为那个不存在的观众写作。我认为阅读他的一种有用的方式是，你可以想到他在说所有这些……基本上你所做的事情并不是在解决与自我、真理、生命或存在有关的问题，你所做的是在玩弄语言的局限性，语言实际上并不让你谈论这些事情，因为它们是来自脑干的反应，描述着像荣格所说的“符号是灵魂的本质”之类的非常深刻的隐喻，但并不总是隐喻。其他时候，它们只是动态过程，因为它们进化了，所以非常复杂。它们涉及像自我与世界、空间意识、听觉记忆和这种能力中连贯的自我感之间的三四个交流节点，所有这些东西，
Maybe the nature of the human self doesn't change that much, but the reality of the human self changes quite a bit because the world around it is so different. Like I just walked you from there from the seventies to the mid 2000s on that part four and explained like why those forces change psychotherapy so much because people are bringing things into therapy that just didn't exist in the 60s, like conceptions of life that weren't there. And you just couldn't be Freud anymore. Like you had to start making these other things. A lot of those guesses are wrong. A lot of those guesses are overreactions to other things. I'm doing that with are wrong. A lot of those guesses are overreactions to other things.
就像……我的意思是，也许是无意识，也许是三级或二级认知过程，也许是内隐记忆，无论你想怎么称呼它。有些过程我们真的不能说“好吧，我对时间的定义是……”，你不能这样做，因为你的大脑体验它的方式非常复杂。所以维特根斯坦正在等待的是人们停止争论这些东西的时候。因为这有点像数学，如果你是数学家并且你喜欢它，那就去做吧。我没意见。
I'm doing that with my therapy. I'm doing that with my series. Like no one's an exception from it. Like I'm not a prophet. I don't know. I tend to think that it's safer to give the patient more control over their reality and that it is also safer to be more integrative in your approach so that when you're trying to understand the self in
我所谈论的，因为我认为治疗应该是物质的、有影响力的和有帮助的，我对哲学中帮助我们做到这一点的部分感兴趣，我对那些只是为了无缘无故地列出东西而帮助我们的部分并不真正感兴趣。很多数学是真实的和应用的，很多东西是永远无法真正……它只是为了好玩，它是完全理论和概念性的，你无法通过图灵机让它成为现实。所以正在发生的一些事情，尤其是
the world that the patient inhabits you're being more flexible um i i've been hurt in therapy like i talked about you know the guy that was like wild and incompetent i'm kind of laughing about it because it's so crazy but like i had ptsd from that you know um i had to go see another therapist uh it's not if something like that has happened to you, I don't take it lightly. Um, and it was very painful when it happened to me. I'm not here to talk about that, but you know, this stuff is important and I see psychotherapy being more therapeutic, um, than a lot of these other like disciplines that are basically talking about self and life. I love anthropology. I love sociology. I like philosophy, but I just don't swim in those waters. You know, maybe the Jungian thing puts me in conversation
分析哲学，我认为就像研究虚数。你知道，我记得当他们说：“嘿，别在中学读《时光之轮》和《指环王》了。把那些放回你的工装裤里，现实一点，学习数学里的这些虚数。”就像是，“伙计，至少我的想象力很有趣。你在谈论一个虚数，负数的平方根。我不关心。我仍然不关心。”如果你喜欢它，那很好。我只是在谈论大多数分析哲学所具有的实际应用。我认为维特根斯坦就像在等待那些争论结束，只是说：“拜托，当这一切结束时，我们可以意识到我们正在谈论的是非常复杂的，我们可以完善
with anthropology and self and philosophy. But one of the things that I think that Peterson's doing that's not helpful and that a lot of these newer guys are doing just because like it works to sell a brand and to get people on YouTube to like leave a comment that's like, wow, I'm not smart enough to understand any of these words, but I am smart enough to know that it's the smartest thing ever. And this guy's right. And it's like, okay, well, uh, yeah, that isn't how that works. Um, but the, the thing that Peterson's doing is like a very surface level reading of Carl Young and a very surface level reading of, um,
语言以更好地反映这种对某种有用的东西的真实意义的追求，而且我们也可以建立一种为私人语言留出空间的语言，它可以留出一种可以留出一种可以表达那些……不是我们不能表达的东西，但它可以为我们无法表达或指代的东西留出空间。也许像一种负空间的语言，会是某种解决方案。所以再说一次，我不想离得太远，但治疗正在与同样的问题作斗争，因为它处理的是内隐记忆，对吧？所以，自我的概念在我的一生中发生了很大的变化。我并没有活那么久，你知道，我的意思是，已经有一段时间了，但在宏观层面上，
Merch Eliane, where he's saying that like all religions are saying the same thing. And then if you go in and you just shave off like every single bit of detail in the myth and everything from the Hebrew Bible, um, or the, you know Hebrew Bible or the Talmud or whatever that is actually making fun of like Babylonia or making fun of the Roman Empire and saying that those things are bad and that they'll get destroyed by kind of tweaking their myths. Like if you just take that all away, then underneath it really like all religion are the same
我不重要，我认为……你知道，有人说“嘿，这只是一种语言混乱，它不是真的”，这正是他所等待的时代，而这正是像斯洛特戴克那样的人……为什么我认为他与众不同，他只是在那个假设下运作。他就像“这些东西都不起作用”，你明白我的意思吗？重点是你有一个框架可以帮助你理解这些东西。重点是你有一个框架让我们理解过去所有的争论，以及不同人之间的所有分歧，以及每个人在说什么，为什么这对他们的时代很重要，为什么现在是这个时代。这有点像……它不完全是批判理论，批判
and they just have the same myths and they just have the same archetypes. I mean, I like the jungian stuff archetypes exist but to separate like everything from culture in a way that that is that reductive and just be like we can use jung to show us basically like the cartesian principles we can use this jung in this way that is cartesian to show us like all these things that are present inside of every myth. So they're like first principles that we have to live by. I mean, it's just very apparent that he's doing that. Not because that's like an interesting way to like help anybody or find knowledge or find anything new, but because he believes a bunch of things that he wants you to believe. And he's spinning his tires in the mud intellectually to try and come
理论是说，你基本上提出了一个分析，然后世界变了，然后那个分析就不再起作用了，所以你必须提出一个及时的分析，并对它进行一些批判理论，以确保它实际上在解决你试图解决的问题，在你试图解决它的时间，并且你正在预见历史的计时器向前滴答作响，一个新事物即将到来。他不是在做批判理论，但他是在为现代哲学和历史哲学中存在的每一个概念留出空间，而不是说对、错、好、坏，而是说：“在这里，在这里，在这里，在这里。这就是它如何与其他事物碰撞。”我
up with a way you know the same thing Nietzsche's critiquing to say my belief that I want you to have that I like I'm so emotional about and desperately need to be your reality also and need to be true I've proved as true with reason which is kind of a dangerous thing to do I think because like reason and logic and all that debate clubby philosophy stuff, I just think is silly. I mean, somebody like Wickenstein is maybe waiting for a time like now. Like, he was very famous about saying, like, I don't really like the people who like me, and I'm writing for a later generation. Like, you get, if you've played Assassin's Creed, the first one, like way back way, when, or maybe maybe it's in the second or third, but it's one of the early ones. It's before Ubisoft turned it into Assassin's Creed universe or whatever.
意思是，你想看看像球体、泡沫和气泡之类的东西。那就是他所说的。我认为这些东西与心理学极其相关。这些是哲学中重叠部分如此强烈，以至于我们无法忽视的部分。我的意思是，如果你能看看，好吧，看，这是古代世界，对吧？你从公元前4000年到公元500年。你有像印度教、佛教、犹太教、基督教的前身、伊斯兰教这样的宗教。
There's a place where the character from the past, his memories are being read by a character in the future, he's like been dead for a thousand years um there's also a scene like it like dune that probably would have been a more like educated like i have many seasoned books type of uh persona if i had quoted dune but it doesn't matter the the character is like i don't understand in the past the character is like his mind is being read by a character in the future is like i don't understand why you're telling me this and the person's like because i'm not talking to you i'm talking through you and they're like yeah but why they're like be quiet just remember this because someone's going to read your brain in 2 000 years or it's not quite that long um don't come at me i'm not a history guy either don't come at me um but the wickenstein would say like I'm kind of writing for an age that's, like, after this. And one, like, really good way to maybe read him is to read him as if he was saying, and he changes a lot and people fight about it.
有一个地方，过去的角色，他的记忆正在被未来的角色读取，他就像已经死了一千年一样。嗯，还有一个场景，就像《沙丘》里的那样，如果我引用了《沙丘》，那可能显得更有教养，像那种读过很多书的人，但这不重要。那个角色说，我不明白，在过去，那个角色说，他的思想正在被未来的角色读取，他说，我不明白你为什么要告诉我这些，那个人说，因为我不是在跟你说话，我是在通过你说话。他们说，是的，但为什么？他们说，安静点，记住这一点，因为两千年后会有人读取你的大脑，或者时间没那么长，嗯，别来找我麻烦，我也不是研究历史的，别来找我麻烦。嗯，但维特根斯坦会说，我是在为这个时代之后的一个时代写作。而且，一种非常好的解读他的方式，就是把他当作是在说这些话，他改变了很多，人们对此争论不休。
I'm not saying that I, like, know how to interpret any of this stuff. I don't specialize in it. These are tertiary dilettante silly impressions that hopefully you, as somebody who is interested in the progression of therapy, or a therapist, or a patient in therapy, and hopefully both, can be like, oh, I'll apply that to my therapeutic technique and the dilettante, fun, liberal arts, I don't really understand it, but I want to play with it way that I think therapy should do. And therapists kind of always have done. a whole bunch about the disciplines that he talked about and he said way more crazy stuff that was like way more written off by everybody who was in those fields uh specialized in those individual fields when he put them together so yeah it doesn't always really help you to know a lot um but like wickenstein is saying that he's basically like writing for this age that hasn't come yet and he's writing for an audience that isn't there and i think one of the ways that is useful to read him is that what you can think about is that he's saying all of these like basically what
我并不是说我知道如何解读这些东西。我不擅长这个。这些都是三手的、业余的、愚蠢的印象，希望你作为一个对治疗进展感兴趣的人，或者治疗师，或者正在接受治疗的病人，最好两者兼具，能够说，哦，我会把它应用到我的治疗技术中，以一种我认为治疗应该有的、业余的、有趣的、自由主义的方式。治疗师们一直以来都是这样做的。他谈论的学科有很多，而且他说了很多更疯狂的话，当他把这些东西放在一起时，那些在各自领域专门研究的人几乎都否定了他，所以是的，知道得太多并不总是有帮助。但维特根斯坦说他基本上是在为这个尚未到来的时代写作，他是在为一群不存在的观众写作，我认为解读他的一种有用的方式是，你可以认为他是在说所有这些，基本上就是
you're doing are not solving problems that have to do with self or truth or life or being what you're doing is playing games with the limitations of language that language doesn't actually let you talk about these things because their reactions from the brainstem that are describing like very profound sometimes metaphors like jung would say that the symbol is the nature of the soul or something but not always metaphors like other times they're just dynamic processes that are so complicated because they've evolved they involve like three or four nodes of communication between like self and world and spatial awareness and auditory memory and like coherent sense of self in this capacity like all these things that
你所做的并不是在解决与自我、真理、生命或存在有关的问题，你所做的是在玩弄语言的局限性，因为语言实际上并不允许你谈论这些事情，因为它们是来自脑干的反应，描述的是一些非常深刻的隐喻，有时像荣格所说的，象征是灵魂的本质之类的，但并不总是隐喻，有时它们只是动态的过程，非常复杂，因为它们已经进化了，它们涉及自我与世界、空间意识、听觉记忆以及在这种能力下连贯的自我感之间的三四个交流节点，所有这些事情
are like i mean maybe the unconscious maybe tertiary uh or secondary cognitive processes maybe implicit memory, like whatever you want to call it. Like there are processes that we can't really say, well, my definition of time is that you can't do it because the way that your brain
就像，我是说，也许是潜意识，也许是三级或二级认知过程，也许是内隐记忆，随你怎么称呼它。有些过程我们无法真正说出来，好吧，我对时间的定义是你无法做到这一点，因为你的大脑
is experiencing it is very complicated. And so what Wittgenstein is kind of waiting for is when people stop fighting about this stuff. Because it's sort of like in math where, and if you're a mathematician and you like it, do it. I'm fine with you doing anything that you like.
体验它的方式非常复杂。所以维特根斯坦所等待的是人们停止为此争论的时候。因为这有点像数学，如果你是一位数学家并且你喜欢它，那就去做吧。我不在乎你做任何你喜欢的事情。
What I'm talking about, because I think that therapy is supposed to be material, impactful, and helpful, and I'm interested in the parts of philosophy that help us do that, I'm not really interested in the parts of it that just help us make lists of stuff for no reason. A lot of mathematics is real and applied, and a lot of it is stuff that can never actually like it's just for fun like it's completely theoretical and conceptual and you couldn't put it through a Turing machine and make it real and so some of the things that are happening and especially
我所谈论的，是因为我认为治疗应该是实质性的、有影响力的和有帮助的，我对哲学中那些能帮助我们做到这一点的部分感兴趣，我并不真正对那些只是帮助我们无缘无故列出东西的部分感兴趣。很多数学是真实的和应用的，而很多数学是永远无法实现的，它只是为了好玩，它是完全理论化和概念化的，你无法通过图灵机让它成为现实，所以正在发生的一些事情，尤其是
analytical philosophy I think are like studying like imaginary numbers you know I remember when they were like hey quit reading will of time and Lord of the Rings in like middle school. Pull your, put those back in your cargo pants and get real and learn these imaginary numbers in math. And it was like, dude, like at least my imagination is interesting. You're talking about an imaginary number, the square root of a negative number. Like, I don't care. I still don't care. And if you like it, that's great. I'm just talking about the practical application that most of analytical philosophy has. I think Wittgenstein is like waiting for those fights to be done and is just like, please, when this is all over, what we can do is realize that what we're talking about is very complicated and that we can refine
分析哲学，我认为就像研究虚数一样。你知道，我记得当他们说，嘿，别在初中读《时光之轮》和《指环王》了。把那些放回你的工装裤里，现实一点，学习数学里的这些虚数。当时我就想，伙计，至少我的想象力很有趣。你在谈论一个虚数，负数的平方根。我不关心。我仍然不关心。如果你喜欢它，那很好。我只是在谈论大多数分析哲学所具有的实际应用。我认为维特根斯坦是在等待那些争论结束，他只是说，拜托，当这一切结束时，我们可以意识到我们所谈论的是非常复杂的，我们可以改进
language to better reflect like this real meaning for search for something that does something and that also we we can build a language that leaves room for a private language it can leave a language that can leave a language that can say things that that not that we can't say but it can leave room for things that we can't say or refer to it. Maybe like a language of the negative space, like would be a solution to something. So again, I don't want to get too far away, but therapy is struggling with that same problem as it deals with implicit memory, right? So like the notion of self has changed so much in my lifetime. And I haven't really been alive for that long you know I mean it it's been a while but in the grand scheme of things like
语言以更好地反映这种对某种有实际作用的东西的真实意义的追求，而且我们也可以建立一种语言，为私人语言留出空间，它可以留出一种语言，一种可以说出那些我们不是不能说，但可以为我们无法说出或指代的事物留出空间的东西。也许像一种负空间的语言，会是某种解决方案。所以再说一次，我不想偏离太远，但治疗正在努力解决同样的问题，因为它处理的是内隐记忆，对吧？所以，自我的概念在我的一生中发生了很大的变化。我活的时间其实并不长，你知道，我的意思是，虽然已经有一段时间了，但在宏观层面上，就像
I don't matter a ton and I think that um you know somebody's saying hey this is just kind of linguistic confusion it's not actually real is sort of the age that he's waiting for and that's the kind of thing that somebody like slaughter deke why i think he's different he's just operating under that assumption he's being like none of this stuff works you kind of know what i mean like the point is that you have a framework that helps you understand the stuff the point is that you have a framework that lets us understand all the fights of the past and all the splits between the different people and what everyone else was saying and why that was relevant to their time and why it's this time now and it's sort of like it's not exactly critical theory which critical
我并不重要，我认为，嗯，你知道有人说，嘿，这只是一种语言上的困惑，它并不是真正真实的，这正是他所等待的时代，这就是像斯洛特戴克那样的人，我认为他与众不同，他只是在那个假设下运作，他就像说，这些东西都没用，你明白我的意思吗？重点是你有一个框架可以帮助你理解这些东西，重点是你有一个框架让我们理解过去所有的争论，以及不同人之间的所有分歧，以及其他人都在说什么，为什么这与他们的时代相关，为什么现在是这个时代，这有点像，它不完全是批判理论，因为批判
theory is saying that basically you come up with an analysis and then the world changes and then that doesn't work anymore so you have to come up with a timely analysis and and and run some critical theory on it to make sure that it's actually working to solve the problem that you're trying to solve at the time you're trying to solve it and you're anticipating the timer of history ticking onward and a new thing coming um he's not like doing critical theory but he's like leaving room for every concept that exists in modern philosophy and historic philosophy and not saying right wrong good bad but saying like saying like, here it is, here it is, here it is, here it is. Here's how it's like bumping up against the other thing. I
理论是说，基本上你提出了一个分析，然后世界变了，然后那个分析就不再适用了，所以你必须提出一个及时的分析，并对其进行一些批判理论的运作，以确保它确实能解决你试图解决的问题，在你试图解决它的那个时候，你正在预见历史的计时器在滴答作响，新的事物即将到来。他不是在做批判理论，但他是在为现代哲学和历史哲学中存在的每一个概念留出空间，不是说对错好坏，而是说，就像说，它在这里，它在这里，它在这里，它在这里。这就是它如何与其他事物碰撞的。我
mean, you want to look at something like spheres and foams and bubbles. Like that's what, that's what he's saying. And those things I think are wildly relevant to, um, psychology. Those are the parts of philosophy where the overlap is so strong that we can't ignore them. I mean, if you can look at, like, okay, look, here's the ancient world, right? You go from 4000 BCE to 500 CE. You've got religions like Hinduism, Buddhism, Judaism, precursors to Christianity, Islam.
意思是，你想看看像球体、泡沫和气泡之类的东西。这就是他所说的。我认为这些东西与心理学极其相关。这些是哲学中重叠部分非常强烈的地方，我们无法忽视它们。我的意思是，如果你能看看，好吧，看，这是古代世界，对吧？你从公元前4000年到公元500年。你有像印度教、佛教、犹太教、基督教的前身、伊斯兰教这样的宗教。
All of these things people are exploring spiritually. And the psychotic experiences that people are having, they're like spirit possessions, divine beings coming into the world. They're handling all of these archetypes in this way that is almost completely similar across all of those things. Like there's cultural things like there's cultural differences because there's different parts of self they're going to be repressed or not allowed or shamed but people sort of understand like hey you know we try and deal with these forces we try and talk about them in this language and then sometimes they get so strong that we call it like spiritual spirituality when the demon or the prophet is here and the space is liminal and that was sort
人们正在精神层面上探索所有这些事物。人们所经历的那些精神病性体验，就像是灵魂附体，或是神灵降临世间。他们以一种在所有这些事物中几乎完全相同的方式处理所有这些原型。就像存在文化层面的东西，因为自我中不同的部分会被压抑、不被允许或感到羞耻，所以存在文化差异，但人们多少能理解，嘿，你知道，我们试图处理这些力量，我们试图用这种语言来谈论它们，有时它们变得如此强烈，以至于当恶魔或先知出现，且处于阈限空间时，我们称之为灵性，而这在某种程度上
of the nature of what psychosis looked like then you've got the middle ages where there's like witches demon possession people becoming saints demons witnessing divine visions you know seeing hell that was like big fight from the medieval ages to the renaissance whether or not like anyone had seen hell and if these artists and writers writing about it were actually going there um and the you know doctrine you're trying to solve psychology uh or you know psychotic experience in this religious way or treating it like it has this religious character in a way that is new because it isn't just, um, it wasn't just kind of the open, like, I mean, bad things happen to you if you were psychotic in the Bronze Age. Like, I'm not saying that there was like a great time. This isn't, I'm not making an argument about like, oh, the noble,
就是当时精神病的样子。然后到了中世纪，有女巫、恶魔附身、人们成为圣徒、恶魔见证神圣幻象，你知道，看到地狱。从中世纪到文艺复兴时期，关于是否有人见过地狱，以及这些书写它的艺术家和作家是否真的去过那里，一直存在着巨大的争论。嗯，你知道，教义试图以这种宗教方式解决心理学问题，或者说解决精神病性体验，或者将其视为具有一种新的宗教特征，因为它不仅仅是，嗯，它不仅仅是那种开放的，我的意思是，如果你在青铜时代患有精神病，糟糕的事情就会发生在你身上。我是说，我并不是说那是一个美好的时代。我不是在争论什么高尚的，
whatever. But there was a different character when the Catholic church is burning witches for heresy. Um, then when people are just sort of like looking at jesus go up to the madman and like touch them to try and you know bring a demon out of them um there's more of kind of like an institutional rigidity that is letting some people in the fold and some people out but there's less of like this natural experience of the angelic and the demonic that just sort of happens there's like a very like in the medieval period like fear of holding on to the good holding on to the angelic holding on to the holy repressing everything else killing it um that starts to drive culture in like a very different way than when you just kind
什么的。但是当罗马天主教会因为异端邪说而烧死女巫时，其性质就不同了。嗯，这与人们只是看着耶稣走向疯子并试图触摸他们以试图，你知道，把恶魔从他们身上赶出来时的情况不同。这更多是一种制度上的僵化，让一些人留在教内，而让一些人被排斥在外，但那种关于天使和恶魔的自然体验却减少了。在中世纪，有一种非常强烈的恐惧，即紧紧抓住善良的东西，紧紧抓住天使般的东西，紧紧抓住神圣的东西，压抑其他一切，消灭它，嗯，这开始以一种非常不同的方式驱动文化，而不是当你只是
of have the bronze age and people having spiritual experiences of good, bad mixed together. You know, all of them are sort of awful, terrible, inevitable, and mystical and complex. The medieval period, there's very much a binary where there are good ones, bad ones. And if you're going to have a good one, the church is probably going to be very suspicious of it. So, like, then, you know the renaissance early modern period you have the reformation you have scientific advancement you have people basically making things that compete with the church in a way that it's not artwork it's not poetic it's not abstract it's not just like giving you an experience of because that's why we looked at like sculptures and paintings and beautiful rooms, right?
处于青铜时代，人们拥有好坏混杂的精神体验时。你知道，所有这些体验在某种程度上都是可怕的、糟糕的、不可避免的、神秘且复杂的。中世纪时期，存在着非常明显的二元对立，即有好的，也有坏的。如果你要拥有一个好的体验，教会很可能会对此非常怀疑。所以，然后，你知道文艺复兴和近代早期，你有了宗教改革，有了科学进步，人们基本上制造出了一些与教会竞争的东西，它不是艺术品，不是诗意的，不是抽象的，它不仅仅是给你一种体验，因为这就是为什么我们看雕塑、绘画和美丽的房间，对吧？
It was to have this like, wow, liminal experience like before film. And it's not, technology becomes not an experience the church can take credit for. You know, in the way that they can say you're feeling the glory of God and you're witnessing this beautiful carving of a saint that we paid for Da Vinci to make. Like you can't do that with something like the steam engine. You can't do that with something like Galileo's model of the universe. Um, because it starts trying to explain things in a way that the church loses control over. And there's this, you know, um, feeling of like secrets of secret societies of like secret motivations. You know, a lot of the, uh, psychological problems that start to come
那是为了获得这种，哇，像电影出现之前的阈限体验。而且，技术不再是教会可以居功的体验。你知道，他们可以说你感受到了上帝的荣耀，你正在见证这件我们付钱给达芬奇制作的精美圣徒雕刻。你不能用蒸汽机之类的东西做到这一点。你不能用伽利略的宇宙模型之类的东西做到这一点。嗯，因为它开始试图以一种教会失去控制的方式来解释事物。而且有一种，你知道，嗯，关于秘密社团、关于秘密动机的感觉。你知道，许多开始出现的心理问题
about are more, uh, stressful, uh, to the person because they're not just like an experience that totally possesses you and takes you over. They're a paranoia. Like you start to get a paranoia about a world under the world, under the world and competing factions. Um, And that's what's happening politically, too. Like, when you move into the 19th century, you see new religious movements, you see like more secularization, you see modern technology. This is the first time where psychosis starts to become something that has to do with like, the government that has to do with um but not just government like i don't want taxes government like that there were giant forces that were could change the fate of the entire world not just like maybe florence falls in my city falls and i can't
更，嗯，令人压力巨大，嗯，对个人而言，因为它们不仅仅是一种完全占据你并控制你的体验。它们是一种偏执。就像你开始对一个世界之下的世界，以及相互竞争的派系产生偏执。嗯。而且在政治上也是如此。就像当你进入19世纪时，你看到了新的宗教运动，你看到了更多的世俗化，你看到了现代技术。这是精神病第一次开始与政府有关，与，嗯，不仅仅是政府，我不想要税收政府，而是说存在着巨大的力量，它们可以改变整个世界的命运，不仅仅是，也许佛罗伦萨沦陷了，我的城市沦陷了，我无法
fathom that or maybe it sort of starts with the crusades, I think, and then goes faster and faster, where people are like, the entire world as I can conceive of it may be manipulated or destroyed. And then that definitely continues to ramp up until you get the atomic bomb. And we can destroy the world, not just slowly through some miscalculation, but like in a second and then you know that continues until you have you know the idea now of global warming and environmental ecological catastrophe running out of food overfishing you know land masses sinking into the ocean because there's this field being that like not only that the world could disappear in the second like a thermonuclear war and fallout and all that but the world could be disappearing every single second underneath our feet while we're doing other things and we don't even notice you
理解这一点，或者也许它始于十字军东征，我想，然后越来越快，人们会说，我所能构想的整个世界可能会被操纵或摧毁。然后这种情况肯定会持续升级，直到原子弹出现。我们可以摧毁世界，不仅仅是通过某种误算缓慢地摧毁，而是像在一秒钟内，然后你知道这种情况会持续下去，直到你有了，你知道，现在关于全球变暖和生态灾难、食物耗尽、过度捕捞、你知道陆地沉入海洋的想法，因为存在着这种存在感，不仅是世界可能在一秒钟内消失，像热核战争和放射性尘埃等等，而且世界可能在我们做其他事情时，每一秒都在我们脚下消失，而我们甚至没有注意到，你
know which is creates a different kind of anxiety or is like more you know upsetting maybe than something like the atomic bomb um in a different way you know i would definitely prefer global warming to global nuclear destruction you you know. But ideally neither. But, like, in the 50s, you know, you had delusions and psychosis were, like, most often reported as, like, persecution, grandeur, control. You know, you get hypophrenic schizophrenia, which is disorganized speech and behavior, just kind of more erratic acting. You know, antipsychotic medications, like first start to come out. But a lot of that is post-war recovery and emergence of the Cold War. And this idea of geopolitical bipolarization, religious experience is this resurgent,
知道，这创造了一种不同类型的焦虑，或者比原子弹之类的东西更，你知道，令人不安，嗯，以一种不同的方式，你知道，我肯定更喜欢全球变暖而不是全球核毁灭，你，你知道。但理想情况下两者都不要。但是，就像在50年代，你知道，你所拥有的妄想和精神病，最常被报告为，像，被迫害、夸大、控制。你知道，你得了多动型精神分裂症，也就是言语和行为紊乱，只是表现得更古怪。你知道，抗精神病药物，像开始出现。但其中很多是战后恢复和冷战的兴起。以及这种地缘政治两极分化的想法，宗教体验是一种复苏的，
you know, thing, even though it's changing, it's supposed to be protecting you from this existential anxiety, which means that it gets fused a whole lot with government, that, you know, American mainstream Christianity sort of becomes this not force that's supposed to be separate from or moderating capitalism or American politics. It's the same as it because the Soviets are not Christian and we are. And so it becomes this monoculture in a way that changes things. In the 60s, you know, you get delusions that are more about like culture and politics and the political climate and people watching you, themes related to
你知道，事物，即使它正在改变，它本应保护你免受这种存在主义焦虑的影响，这意味着它与政府融合了很多，你知道，美国主流基督教在某种程度上变成了这种力量，而不是应该与资本主义或美国政治分离或调节它的力量。它与它是一样的，因为苏联人不是基督徒，而我们是。所以它以一种改变事物的方式变成了一种单一文化。在60年代，你知道，你得到的妄想更多是关于文化和政治，以及政治气候和监视你的人，与
like Cold War espionage. It's like the John Nash paranoia of, you know, connecting the dots. You get this idea of like seeing and connecting patterns. Whereas before those patterns were just like, I am an angel. I am a devil. I have a thousand demons in me i am they're they're turning into that you could read the phone book and see what the ussr or the devil is doing you know there's the the increasing um nature of like surveillance and technology that is putting
像冷战间谍活动相关的主题。这就像约翰·纳什的偏执，你知道，把点连起来。你有了这种看到和连接模式的想法。而在此之前，这些模式只是，我是天使。我是魔鬼。我身上有一千个恶魔，我，它们正在变成你可以阅读电话簿并看到苏联或恶魔在做什么，你知道，存在着，嗯，监视和技术日益增加的性质，它正在把
things into categories and information being represented starts to affect the way that we have psychotic episodes. Because the nature of self is changing. Because the world around it is changing. And so therapy had to change. In the 70s, you have delusions that start to have elements of science fiction. They start to have actual technology in them. People are saying things all of a sudden like that you know invisible lasers and ray guns
事物分类，而信息的呈现方式开始影响我们产生精神病发作的方式。因为自我的本质正在改变。因为周围的世界正在改变。所以治疗必须改变。在70年代，你有了开始具有科幻元素的妄想。它们开始在其中包含实际的技术。人们突然说出一些事情，比如你知道隐形激光和射线枪
and you know alien things things from the the weird science and hp lovecraft stuff start to be what people when they have a psychotic break are experiencing and you know you get this concept of bpd in the 70s which i don't really love the way we conceived of that diagnosis but they basically were saying okay well these people are psychotic because we're asking them what happened. And they're telling us things that everyone saw didn't happen. That's not what they did. But it's not because they're psychotic. It's because they're in so much shame. Like they have so much emotional turmoil that they can't sit with the sense of self of the person who they were when they did that. So it's not a psychotic split. It's an emotional split from reality
以及你知道外星事物，来自怪异科学和洛夫克拉夫特的东西开始成为人们在精神崩溃时所经历的东西，你知道，你在70年代得到了边缘性人格障碍（BPD）这个概念，我并不真正喜欢我们构想该诊断的方式，但他们基本上是在说，好吧，这些人是精神病，因为我们在问他们发生了什么。而他们告诉我们的事情，每个人都看到并没有发生。这不是他们所做的。但这不是因为他们是精神病。这是因为他们处于太多的羞耻感中。就像他们有太多的情绪动荡，以至于他们无法与做那件事时的那个人的自我感共处。所以这不是精神分裂，而是与现实的情绪分裂
where the person who has the borderline personality disorder is saying, well, my sense of self doesn't lie. But we all heard you lie in group. No, no, no, no, no. You're bad because you're telling me that my sense of self isn't real. And my sense of self doesn't do the things you're accusing me of. So my self-image is not lining up with reality. And I kind of need you to enable my self-image that is wrong. And if you won't, I'm going to split, and I'm going to attack you,
其中患有边缘性人格障碍的人说，好吧，我的自我感不会撒谎。但我们都听到你在小组里撒谎了。不，不，不，不，不。你很坏，因为你告诉我我的自我感不是真实的。而我的自我感并没有做你指责我的那些事情。所以我的自我形象与现实不符。我需要你支持我那错误的自我形象。如果你不这样做，我就会分裂，我会攻击你，
and I'm going to say that you're bad, and I'm going to come up with a bunch of made-up reasons. And we all do that to a certain extent. But for the people at that time, they're saying, okay, well, this person is basically not able to do therapy. They're not able to respond to either medication, even though the medication maybe makes them a little bit more palatable, or insight-based therapy because we're trying to tell them things
我会说你很坏，我会编造一堆理由。我们所有人都在一定程度上这样做。但对于当时的人们来说，他们说，好吧，这个人基本上无法进行治疗。他们无法对药物做出反应，即使药物可能使他们稍微好受一点，或者无法对基于洞察力的治疗做出反应，因为我们试图告诉他们一些事情
and they're telling us that that isn't real. And in the 80s, delusion changes a ton. There's a lot of things about infection aids murder paranoia the cia is coming after you um you start to see eating disorders like um anorexia bulimia they get recognition but they also become like a lot more culturally entrenched in what's happening in this culture of kind of like that drugs can control the body and you know you can lose weight on cocaine or you can take this and there's this very externalized sense of self where a lot of things were about how you were perceived you know your your self-image wasn't your self-image, how other people perceived you was your self-image.
而他们告诉我们那不是真的。在80年代，妄想发生了巨大的变化。有很多关于感染、艾滋病、谋杀、偏执的事情，中央情报局在追捕你，嗯，你开始看到饮食失调，像，厌食症、暴食症，它们得到了认可，但它们也变得更加文化性地根深蒂固于这种文化中，即药物可以控制身体，你知道，你可以通过可卡因减肥，或者你可以服用这个，有一种非常外化的自我感，很多事情都是关于你如何被感知，你知道，你的自我形象不是你的自我形象，别人如何感知你才是你的自我形象。
And so, so many of those results of a very corporate, very individualistic, very objectively oriented moneyed society start to change things. You know, in the 90s, people are like more interested in DID like you start to see that um more studied childhood trauma becomes this thing the internet leads to um all kinds of social addictions um you know cyber sexing breaks up marriages where it's like not even not even like the before webcams before anything like people were just chatting and they would, you know, role play these different things. And there's this huge change, um, in this digital age where people now have that same
所以，如此多的那些非常企业化、非常个人主义、非常客观导向的金钱社会的结果开始改变事物。你知道，在90年代，人们对DID（解离性身份障碍）更感兴趣，就像你开始看到，嗯，更多研究的童年创伤成为了一件事，互联网导致了，嗯，各种各样的社会成瘾，你知道，网络性爱破坏了婚姻，就像甚至不是，甚至不是像网络摄像头之前，在任何东西之前，人们只是聊天，他们会，你知道，角色扮演这些不同的事情。而且在这个数字时代，有一个巨大的变化，嗯，人们现在有了那种
paranoia of the eighties of like, what if people don't see me in the right way? Maybe their perception of me is who I am. That's like magnified so much by the internet, which continues into the two way, maybe their perception of me is who I am. That's like magnified so much by the internet, which continues into the two thousands, because you're not just trying to like go on the weekend to church and then make a good impression there and then go to work, you know, the weekday and make a good impression there. And then also have my family, you know, understand me. I'm worried about what my 10,000 YouTube followers will say tomorrow because the celebrity that I like just said this. You know, it's escalating to something like that now.
80年代的偏执，比如，如果人们没有以正确的方式看待我怎么办？也许他们对我的感知就是我是谁。这被互联网放大了这么多，这持续到两千年代，因为你不仅仅是试图在周末去教堂，然后在那里留下好印象，然后在工作日去工作，你知道，留下好印象。然后还要让我的家人，你知道，理解我。我担心我的一万名YouTube粉丝明天会说什么，因为我喜欢的名人刚刚说了这个。你知道，它现在正在升级到那种程度。
And, you know, a ton of things about, like, global conflict and war kick off, like, in Delusions after 9-11. A lot of things about there's sort of another hopelessness that like this thing will never really end like people you know the initial thing is like oh yeah let's go kick some butts and we're americans and then it just slowly becomes this thing that's never going away this anger where you you never the fist can never make contact with anything that's satisfying people still feel like they're the center of the universe, but they're having to think about the experience of American foreign policy and American imperialism and all of these things all around the world in a way that makes them really angry, because I shouldn't have to think about that. That should just happen outside of my experience. And if it
而且，你知道，关于全球冲突和战争的一大堆事情，在9-11之后的妄想中爆发了。很多关于存在另一种绝望的事情，就像这件事永远不会真正结束，就像人们，你知道，最初的事情是，哦，是的，让我们去踢一些屁股，我们是美国人，然后它慢慢变成了这种永远不会消失的事情，这种愤怒，你永远，拳头永远无法接触到任何令人满意的东西，人们仍然觉得他们是宇宙的中心，但他们不得不思考美国外交政策和美国帝国主义以及世界各地所有这些事情的体验，这让他们非常生气，因为我不应该去想这些。那应该只是发生在我的体验之外。如果它
does happen, I should just be able to reduce it down to something that I already understand so that I don't have to learn anything. And y'all keep telling me, as I look at all these things, that there's things that I don't know. And I think that's why you get this kind of like overwhelm and shutdown cycles with the internet, because just collectively, like people cannot drink from this firehose of information. And so when there is a crisis, you know, maybe one of the first technological ones would be something like 9-11. Everyone's very aware and then they're burned out and then they're overwhelmed and then they forget that the war is even happening. And then if you have something that breaks the rules, like, well, Clinton's not supposed to lose.
确实发生了，我应该能够把它简化为我已经理解的东西，这样我就不必学习任何东西了。而你们一直告诉我，当我看着所有这些事情时，有些事情我不知道。我想这就是为什么你在互联网上得到这种像压倒和关闭循环的原因，因为集体来说，就像人们无法从这个信息消防栓中喝水。所以当有危机时，你知道，也许第一个技术性的危机是像9-11这样的事情。每个人都非常清楚，然后他们精疲力竭，然后他们不知所措，然后他们忘记了战争甚至正在发生。然后如果你有打破规则的事情，比如，嗯，克林顿不应该输。
Trump's not somebody like Trump's not supposed to win. Everybody gets online when you have a giant pandemic, and then they just burn out and kind of dissociate because that intensity can't happen. It's like thinking about a wildfire, right? Like, we used to fight wildfires in the 50s with this, like, you know, World War I language of, like, World War II language of, like, they actually would show propaganda films about it.
特朗普不是像特朗普这样的人不应该赢。当你遇到巨大的流行病时，每个人都上网，然后他们只是精疲力竭并产生某种解离，因为那种强度无法持续。这就像思考野火，对吧？就像，我们在50年代用这种，你知道，第一次世界大战的语言，像，第二次世界大战的语言，像，他们实际上会播放关于它的宣传片。
They were like, the wildfire would blow through california and it would devastate the economy and the animals and but here's the exciting music and now we're putting it out and not letting it happen well it ends up like you shouldn't do that because what happens is the amount of fuel just gets so full um everywhere that when the fire happens you can can't stop it. It's just this huge inferno that raises everything. And so there's these release valves that you can see in the internet with this like political system where people have this hyper obsession and it doesn't happen all at once. Like Americans aren't monadic. Like I said that in the beginning, what's going to happen is that certain demographic groups are going to have this thing happen.
他们说，野火会吹过加利福尼亚，它会摧毁经济和动物，但这是令人兴奋的音乐，现在我们正在扑灭它，不让它发生，好吧，结果就像你不应该那样做，因为发生的事情是燃料的数量变得如此充足，嗯，到处都是，以至于当火灾发生时，你无法阻止它。这只是这个巨大的地狱，抬高了一切。所以互联网上有这些释放阀，你可以看到这种政治系统，人们有这种过度痴迷，它不会一下子发生。就像美国人不是单子的。就像我在开头说的那样，将会发生的是，某些人口群体会发生这种事情。
But where you're going to see like the biggest cultural experience is where multiple ones of those demographic groups are overlapping to the same stimuli or multiple stimuli at the same time. They're having a big obsessive engagement with the Internet and then they're leaving, you know. And I don't really love mckenna um but if you want to look at something like terence mckenna's time wave theory um i don't think it works anything like he did but if you want to look at it like a chinese calendar which it probably was something like that in this rise and kind of like you know he would call it novelty in a way that i wouldn't um but that is i think one of the futures of understanding psychology and the intersection of sociology, maybe anthropology and psychotherapy,
但是，你将看到最大的文化体验的地方是，多个那些人口群体在同一时间对相同的刺激或多个刺激重叠。他们正在与互联网进行巨大的痴迷互动，然后他们离开了，你知道。我并不真正喜欢麦肯纳，嗯，但如果你想看像特伦斯·麦肯纳的时间波理论之类的东西，嗯，我不认为它像他所做的那样工作，但如果你想把它看作一个中国历法，它可能就是那样的东西，在这种上升和某种，你知道，他会称之为新奇，以一种我不会的方式，嗯，但我认为这是理解心理学和社会学、也许人类学和心理治疗的交叉点的未来之一，
like what psychotherapy has to do to understand and prepare for these things. And so I don't really like the philosophies that are very reductive. You know, that just say like, okay, well, here's all this stuff. And it all can just be boiled down to these definitions. And this is what time is. This is what being is. This is what life is. Because like Wittgenstein, I don't think that language can encapsulate that.
就像心理治疗为了理解和准备这些事情所要做的那样。所以我并不真正喜欢那些非常还原论的哲学。你知道，那些只是说，好吧，这就是所有这些东西。而这一切都可以归结为这些定义。这就是时间。这就是存在。这就是生命。因为像维特根斯坦一样，我不认为语言可以概括这一点。
And I definitely don't think numbers can. As we've tried to make it in psychotherapy i mean you want to talk about psychology being a soft science i mean philosophy you know is just has to be one of the softest sciences there is right um but then we have to make it empirical somewhat or else what do we fight about? So I think that the things like what Sloterdijk's fears do and what somebody like Marx was trying to do, even though he's not right a bunch of places about it, is build this predictive engine to kind of understand those boom and bust cycles. And I still think that somebody like Jung, and not even really in anything that Jung directly said,
而且我绝对不认为数字可以。正如我们试图在心理治疗中所做的那样，我的意思是，你想谈论心理学是一门软科学，我的意思是，哲学，你知道，必须是现存最软的科学之一，对吧，嗯，但我们必须使它在某种程度上是经验性的，否则我们为什么而争论？所以我认为像斯洛特戴克的恐惧所做的事情，以及像马克思试图做的事情，尽管他在很多地方都不对，是建立这个预测引擎来理解那些繁荣和萧条的周期。而且我仍然认为像荣格这样的人，甚至不是荣格直接说的任何东西，
like I can't point to this in the collective works, I can point to it via implication, where he was dealing with a million problems. He sort of solved some of them. He didn't really get around to going back and doing a lot of it. But the other people like Neumann, that, you know, Jung is kind of like Plato, I think, in psychology. He's probably about as misunderstood as Nietzsche and Plato. But he asks all these questions that you can laugh at him and call him an occultist and like all of these things that don't really reflect anything.
就像我不能在全集中指出这一点，我可以通过暗示指出它，他在处理一百万个问题。他多少解决了一些。他并没有真正腾出时间回去做很多事情。但像诺伊曼这样的人，你知道，荣格在心理学中有点像柏拉图，我想。他可能和尼采和柏拉图一样被误解。但他问了所有这些问题，你可以嘲笑他，称他为神秘主义者，像所有这些并不真正反映任何东西的事情。
But what you can't do is get rid of him because he came he pointed something out that you can't unsee like yeah you can pretend that it isn't there but anyone who reads it and sees those implications of that the culture has these release valves of explosions where when we make certain functions when we become over empirical we repress all of this like felt information, and intuitive information that is still there, whether or not we're listening to it, and then it becomes something like a psychosis, you know, psychosis is always going to reflect somebody who's repressed all this information. Culturally, it's not a magic trick. This is psychology, like you can be completely material and materialist and still understand this, but you're, you're repressing different information based on the place that you're at,
但你不能做的是摆脱他，因为他来了，他指出了你无法忽视的东西，就像是的，你可以假装它不存在，但任何阅读它并看到那些暗示的人，文化有这些爆炸的释放阀，当我们制造某些功能时，当我们变得过度经验主义时，我们压抑了所有这些感受到的信息，以及仍然存在的直觉信息，无论我们是否在听它，然后它就变成了像精神病一样的东西，你知道，精神病总是会反映出压抑了所有这些信息的人。在文化上，这不是魔术。这是心理学，就像你可以完全是物质的和唯物主义的，仍然可以理解这一点，但你，你根据你所处的位置压抑了不同的信息，
which is why something like Peterson saying that you can just use Jung and Eliade. And he doesn't even say that because he doesn't say what he, where his influences come from. You just have to hear the misappropriations of like his assumption. And, and here, you know,
这就是为什么像彼得森说你可以只使用荣格和伊利亚德。而且他甚至没有那样说，因为他没有说他的影响来自哪里。你只需要听到他假设的挪用。而且，在这里，你知道，
he's probably more well-read than than me but he's not more well read about the things that he talks about which is weird um like don't have a debate about Karl Marx if you haven't read Karl Marx you know like he's the first person to be like you have to outline your terms and go in logically okay why haven't you read the thing that you're saying that you know all this stuff about like you why right like don't go into a bait with slobby zizek if you haven't read the material um so like you know it's silly it's like his take on yung is joseph campbell's star wars screenwriter stuff like people like that that feel like everything's under attack and like men need to go back to this
他可能比我读的书多，但他对他所谈论的事情读得并不多，这很奇怪，嗯，就像如果你没有读过卡尔·马克思，就不要辩论卡尔·马克思，你知道，就像他是第一个说你必须概述你的术语并合乎逻辑地进入的人，好吧，为什么你没有读过你所说的你知道所有这些事情的东西，你为什么，对吧，就像不要在没有读过材料的情况下与斯拉沃热·齐泽克进行辩论，嗯，所以，你知道，这很愚蠢，这就像他对荣格的看法是约瑟夫·坎贝尔的《星球大战》编剧的东西，就像那些觉得一切都受到攻击的人，就像男人需要回到这个
primal source and i i am the one to lead them like they used to just write conan the barbarian or like read it they didn't used to have a youtube um and so like those release valves are built in to jung's assumptions about the way that we repress different psychological functions both as individuals and a society and somebody like like Eric Neumann that's saying, well, culture is like all on this journey. And like, you can see the story in mankind as they are growing up through mythology. And it reflects, um, what we understand right now, which now is a misconception about, um, the biology of evolution, um, is also reflecting the psychology of ideological evolution. Like, that isn't right.
原始源头，而我是那个领导他们的人，就像他们过去只是写《野蛮人柯南》或者像读它，他们过去没有YouTube，所以，那些释放阀内置在荣格关于我们作为个人和社会压抑不同心理功能的假设中，而像埃里克·诺伊曼这样的人说，好吧，文化就像都在这段旅程中。而且，你可以看到人类在成长过程中的故事，通过神话。它反映了，嗯，我们现在所理解的，现在是对，嗯，进化生物学的误解，也反映了意识形态进化的心理学。就像，那是不对的。
But it's Neumann picking up, which is probably why Jung liked him, picking up on... Because Jung wondered a lot of things that he didn't say. And he was wondering how we grew up and where it went and what you do with that and neumann makes an answer that's interesting and based on the science of the time but it's still not right you know like origins of history of consciousness there's interesting stuff there
但这是诺伊曼捡起来的，这可能是荣格喜欢他的原因，捡起来……因为荣格想知道很多他没有说的事情。他想知道我们是如何长大的，它去了哪里，你用它做什么，而诺伊曼给出了一个有趣的答案，基于当时的科学，但它仍然是不对的，你知道，就像意识历史的起源，那里有有趣的东西
but it isn't it isn't real um in the way that the new psychology has to be but like a lot like plato you can't get rid of yung like Plato, you can't get rid of Jung's deeper assumptions. You can't get rid of a lot of these things. And like in academic psychology, they would say, okay, well, if you go back to like the person who cited the most, they're the best because the most people had to like recite their paper. I'm not talking about a citation factor. Like I don't see the point of that that but when you look at the history of like civilization if you look at the people who came up with a perennial philosophy because everyone else like maybe somebody also had the same thing in India you know like the white brotherhood or like another mystic but they
但它不是，它不是真实的，以新心理学必须有的方式，但像柏拉图一样，你不能摆脱荣格，像柏拉图一样，你不能摆脱荣格更深层的假设。你不能摆脱很多这些事情。而且在学术心理学中，他们会说，好吧，如果你回到像被引用最多的人那里，他们是最好的，因为最多的人不得不像背诵他们的论文。我不是在谈论引用因素。就像我不明白那一点，但当你观察文明的历史时，如果你观察那些提出永恒哲学的人，因为其他人，也许某个人在印度也有同样的东西，你知道，像白色兄弟会或像另一个神秘主义者，但他们
still got to the same place and society was still beholden to answering the questions that they ask because once they're asked you can't ignore them those are the important like hinge points in building any kind of like interesting culture i don't have an answer for that i don't have like a theory but if you want to look at like what maybe more of a universal religion is like, I think it is finding places. I'm not saying that we should go out and build this religion, but if you want to look at sort of the religion of mankind changing as a comparative religion thing, that isn't just like, okay, well now the Protestant reformation happened, but like, what are people beneath their religious beliefs that they're not even acting on most of the time. They're still killing and adultering and drinking and all of this stuff,
仍然到达了同一个地方，社会仍然有义务回答他们提出的问题，因为一旦提出，你就不能忽视它们，那些是构建任何像有趣文化一样的 hinge points（关键点），我没有答案，我没有像理论，但如果你想看像什么是更普遍的宗教，我想它是寻找地方。我不是说我们应该出去建立这个宗教，但如果你想看人类宗教作为一种比较宗教的东西在改变，那不仅仅是，好吧，现在新教改革发生了，而是，人们在他们的宗教信仰之下是什么，他们甚至大部分时间都没有根据它行事。他们仍然在杀戮、通奸、喝酒和所有这些事情，
even though they say they're one religion. But what do they really believe? You need to go back to these things in implicit memory that everyone is feeling. And it may not be interesting to you to look at any kind of anthropology as a therapist. You just want to deal with individual people. But I still don't think you can get away from the world. And I think that, you know, we are waiting for this next thing that is going to teach us how to ignore the questions that are unimportant. And how to look at the questions
即使他们说他们是一个宗教。但他们真正相信什么？你需要回到这些每个人都在感受的内隐记忆中的东西。作为一名治疗师，看任何人类学可能对你来说并不有趣。你只是想处理个人。但我仍然认为你无法逃离世界。而且我认为，你知道，我们正在等待下一件将教我们如何忽视不重要问题的事情。以及如何看待那些
that maybe will never be answered, but are important enough that we're going to have to sit with. And that's kind of what Sloterdijk is saying. And that's probably what Wittgenstein was waiting for. And if you go back and think about those delusions that I'm talking about, one of the reasons that I'm talking about those is if you want to say, okay, well, there's this simple surface-level problem, and that problem is the reason why delusions change in the culture. Like if you want to say, oh, I'm reactionary right-wing, and the Disney movies were slightly different, and that changed psychosis.
也许永远不会被回答，但足够重要以至于我们将不得不与之共处的问题。这就是斯洛特戴克所说的。这可能就是维特根斯坦在等待的。如果你回去思考我正在谈论的那些妄想，我谈论那些的原因之一是如果你想说，好吧，有一个简单的表面层面的问题，而那个问题是妄想在文化中改变的原因。就像如果你想说，哦，我是反动右翼，而迪士尼电影稍微不同，那改变了精神病。
Or if you want to say, you know, left-wing, well, I just don't think that the president has the values. I remember the president used to have good manners. You know, this isn't not for you because I don't think that a psychotic break has anything to do with those things at all. I think they have to do with the forces that I'm talking about that everyone's feeling and the person with psychosis is expressing in a way that they can't turn off that is very sad but that does give you a glimpse into these social anxieties and so like you know I'd said that the thing that I like about art and culture and anthropology and psychology and to a limited extent philosophy is its ability
或者如果你想说，你知道，左翼，好吧，我只是不认为总统有价值观。我记得总统过去有礼貌。你知道，这不是为你准备的，因为我不认为精神崩溃与这些事情有任何关系。我认为它们与我正在谈论的力量有关，每个人都在感受，而患有精神病的人正在以一种他们无法关闭的方式表达，这非常悲伤，但这确实让你瞥见了这些社会焦虑，所以，你知道，我说过我喜欢艺术、文化、人类学和心理学以及在有限程度上的哲学的一点是它的能力
the artists the things I like about artists and creators and innovators is that they have this intuition that lets them kind of see beyond time right and so when i'm saying feel this tension between the self and the world that's why i'm showing you these um delusional timelines of psychotic breaks and culture is because these are the dreams that become nightmares of the society, right? And they let you get at something. So, you know, if you go through that timeline, you're seeing the way that the culture screams that we don't hear until it's asleep or psychotic. And that this is how you're going to have to figure out how you're hurting and how everyone around you is hurting. And the hurt that you're feeling without knowing is how you watch these
艺术家，我喜欢艺术家、创作者和创新者的事情是他们有这种直觉，让他们能够超越时间，对吧，所以当我说是感受自我和世界之间的这种张力时，这就是为什么我向你展示这些，嗯，精神崩溃和文化的妄想时间线，因为这些是变成社会噩梦的梦，对吧？它们让你接触到一些东西。所以，你知道，如果你经历那个时间线，你正在看到文化尖叫的方式，我们直到它睡着或精神病时才听到。而且这就是你将不得不弄清楚你如何受伤以及你周围的每个人如何受伤的方式。而你不知道地感受到的伤害就是你观察这些
things change. And that's that tension between the self and the world that I think psychology has to not have a working definition for it in the way that like an analytical psychologist would. But a language of the negative space to say, here's what we can't say, but we know it's there, but we can't say it. So let's say what we can say, but let's also talk about the stuff that we can't perfectly quantify and talk about. Um, and Slaughter Deeks model lets you do that. Um, it's an attempt to let you do that in a way that no one else is even attempting right now. I mean, one of the reasons why I ended that fourth series with the conversation between Penn Warren and Dickie James Dickie was that like
事情改变的方式。这就是我认为心理学必须拥有的自我和世界之间的那种张力，不是以分析心理学家那样的方式有一个工作定义。而是一种负空间的语言，说，这是我们不能说的，但我们知道它在那里，但我们不能说它。所以让我们说我们可以说的，但也谈论那些我们不能完美量化和谈论的东西。嗯，斯洛特戴克的模型让你这样做。嗯，这是一种尝试让你以目前没有人甚至在尝试的方式这样做。我的意思是，我结束那个第四系列时使用佩恩·沃伦和迪基·詹姆斯·迪基之间的对话的原因之一是，嗯
I do think that that thing is found in poetry like it is found in symbol like that's what lets us talk about something we can't quite talk about I mean Dickie is basically telling students about his like plans for his own death and under buzzards in a way that like maybe
我确实认为那种东西是在诗歌中找到的，就像它是在符号中找到的一样，这就是让我们谈论我们无法完全谈论的东西，我的意思是迪基基本上是在告诉学生关于他自己死亡的计划，在秃鹰之下，以一种，嗯，也许
he doesn't even know and he writes poetry so weird like uh he writes it like a fist fighter like he clearly likes it but it's so clunky and it's not pretty and it's almost beautiful you know and ben warren is a very good poet and i'm not saying Dickie's a bad one. He's just weird. But, like, we have to tear down the walls between poetry and these influencers that don't, they're basically going back and saying, I want to phrase history as this narrative where every single thing is part of this progression up until this moment where we are under unique threat that has never been faced before and like your moment is totally different and you know unless you're talking about like thermonuclear bombs if you're talking about culture if you're talking about psychology that just isn't and can't ever be true uh in the way that a lot of these people need it to be in order to sell youtube stuff or to feel the ego inflation that they want to feel. Because like nothing that Peterson says is really like a new idea most of the time.
他甚至不知道，他写诗写得如此奇怪，像，嗯，他写得像个拳击手，他显然喜欢它，但它太笨拙了，它不漂亮，它几乎是美丽的，你知道，本·沃伦是一位非常好的诗人，我不是说迪基是个糟糕的诗人。他只是很奇怪。但是，我们必须拆除诗歌和这些影响者之间的墙，他们不，他们基本上是在回去说，我想把历史表述为这种叙事，其中每一件事都是这种进步的一部分，直到这一刻，我们处于前所未有的独特威胁之下，就像你的时刻完全不同，你知道，除非你在谈论像热核炸弹，如果你在谈论文化，如果你在谈论心理学，那根本不是，也不可能永远是真的，嗯，以许多这些人为了销售YouTube东西或为了感受到他们想要感受的自我膨胀而需要它的方式。因为像彼得森所说的任何东西，大多数时候都不是什么新想法。
And again, I'm not picking on him. Like he's not an innovator. He's an academic who wrote to be cited. And he was very successful at that until he decided that he didn't want to be an academic psychologist. He wanted to be sort of like an influencer philosopher. And when he became an influencer philosopher, he needed to be all things to all people. And so he's going to cite all of these things to sound like he understands the interplay between them and to sound like he is
再说一次，我不是在挑剔他。就像他不是创新者。他是一位为了被引用而写作的学者。而且他在那方面非常成功，直到他决定他不想成为学术心理学家。他想成为某种像影响者哲学家。当他成为影响者哲学家时，他需要成为所有人的所有东西。所以他会引用所有这些东西来听起来像他理解它们之间的相互作用，并听起来像他是
smart. And he is a very intelligent person, you know, a lot smarter than me. But the way that he is picking information is to make it part of this narrative that needs to retroject, you know, go back and insert things into people that just fundamentally weren't there. There wasn't like society figuring things out slowly over time. It was like people doing it right up until a point where they did it wrong and he can take you back there. And tons of people do this. You know, it's a pretty common tactic. But listen to this. What philosophy is, you know, it's two things.
聪明的。而且他是一个非常聪明的人，你知道，比我聪明得多。但他选择信息的方式是使其成为这种叙事的一部分，这种叙事需要回溯，你知道，回去并插入一些根本不存在的东西到人们身上。并没有像社会随着时间的推移慢慢弄清楚事情。就像人们一直这样做，直到他们做错的一点，他可以带你回到那里。而且很多人这样做。你知道，这是一个非常常见的策略。但听听这个。什么是哲学，你知道，它是两件事。
It's not complicated. What philosophy is, is the ability to critique arguments and make arguments. And it is the ability to understand the context of arguments that have been made before. And so you can get the first part really right and feel smart, and you can get the second part really wrong, and you're more better off than if you're more better off. You can get the first part right, and you can mess up the second part, and you'd be better off if you had never done the first one at all,
这并不复杂。什么是哲学，是批判论点和提出论点的能力。它是理解之前已经做出的论点的背景的能力。所以你可以把第一部分做得非常好，感觉自己很聪明，而你可以把第二部分做得非常糟糕，你比如果你，你比如果你更好。你可以把第一部分做对，你可以把第二部分搞砸，如果你从来没有做过第一部分，你会更好，
if you had just left it alone, because the context is the thing that matters right um like the context is the thing that makes plato you know saying a different thing or that makes aristotle saying a different thing than descartes in the way that peterson can't let them because they both have to be neoplatonists. And anybody who is making that kind of argument, I think is sort of dangerous. And again, I don't care what you think about Jordan Peterson. I don't think debating him or something is useful. What I'm pointing to him as is one of these inevitabilities of culture
如果你只是让它顺其自然，因为背景才是重要的事情，嗯，就像背景是让柏拉图，你知道，说不同事情的东西，或者让亚里士多德说出与笛卡尔不同的东西，以彼得森不能让他们那样做的方式，因为他们都必须是新柏拉图主义者。而且任何正在提出那种论点的人，我认为在某种程度上是危险的。再说一次，我不在乎你怎么看乔丹·彼得森。我不认为辩论他或什么是有用的。我指出他是文化的这些必然性之一
that he's ignoring, right? And he has to ignore it because as is one of these inevitabilities of culture that he's ignoring, right? And he has to ignore it because he is one of these release valves of this energy that, like, isn't being talked about and isn't being addressed. But the reason why somebody ignoring that context is so scary is that while the language is fundamentally reductive, it's also very empty. So think about Sloterdijk's idea of foams, that you have a hundred people that are sort of believing the same things and all those foams are intention, but they're all in their own different bubble of meaning making. So when you get a group of people together who's listening to somebody and they're like, we want to be religious, but without religion, or we want this to be religion, but we also don't think we're religious
他正在忽视，对吧？而且他必须忽视它，因为他是这种能量的释放阀之一，这种能量，就像，没有被谈论，也没有被解决。但某个人忽视那个背景之所以如此可怕，是因为虽然语言在根本上是还原论的，但它也是非常空洞的。所以想想斯洛特戴克的泡沫概念，你有一百个人在某种程度上相信同样的事情，所有这些泡沫都在张力中，但它们都在它们自己不同的意义制造气泡中。所以当你把一群正在听某人说话的人聚在一起，他们就像，我们想成为宗教的，但没有宗教，或者我们想让这成为宗教，但我们也认为我们不是宗教的
in a way like that. It's scary because you have a lot of zealots, but it's not a crusade because they're not even responding to a coherent idea or a coherent energy because there aren't really coherent ideas there. In order to appeal to everybody, like you can't really say anything wrong, but you can't say anything new. So you have to make everything that you're saying very simple in its nature, but you have to believing all of this stuff that is like on its face so absurd that there's no soul or whatever and then you claim that what
某种程度上是这样的。这很可怕，因为你有很多狂热分子，但这并不是一场十字军东征，因为他们甚至没有在回应一个连贯的思想或连贯的能量，因为那里根本没有连贯的思想。为了迎合所有人，你不能说错任何话，但你也说不出任何新东西。所以你必须把你所说的一切本质上都变得非常简单，但你必须相信所有这些表面上看起来如此荒谬的东西，以至于没有灵魂之类的，然后你声称你所做的是解决问题的唯一方案
you're doing is the only solution to fix it instead of sitting with this bigger question that we don't really know one that like maybe cleaning up your room or voting for this person has nothing to do with addressing the moment that we're in. And there's a splitting that you have to do that comes from the Iliade that Jordan Peterson is misappropriating. It comes from the very surface level reading of Jung, where what he's saying is, okay, everything out here is order and everything out here is chaos. And I'm on the side of order, but you feel anxiety. So let me explain to you where the chaos is in the world in a way that flatters your biases by attributing it to people who already make you uncomfortable. You just didn't know why. And now I'm telling you that it's this
而不是去面对我们并不真正了解的那个更大的问题，比如打扫房间或投票给某个人可能与解决我们所处的时代毫无关系。你必须进行一种分裂，这种分裂来自乔丹·彼得森（Jordan Peterson）所挪用的《伊利亚特》。它来自对荣格（Jung）非常表面的解读，他所说的是，好吧，这里的一切都是秩序，那里的一切都是混乱。我站在秩序这一边，但你感到了焦虑。所以让我来向你解释世界上的混乱在哪里，通过将其归咎于那些已经让你感到不舒服的人来迎合你的偏见。你只是不知道为什么。现在我告诉你，这是
esoteric spiritual project that transcends time by quoting philosophers contextually wrong. When you do that, like you're not really being anything. You have to appeal to all of these people. And the way that you appeal to them is that you tell them that history is this sort of secret code that validates all their assumptions in a way that sounds smart. But you can't also, and you're the only one that sees it, and they can see it with your help. And I don't think Peterson's lying. I mean, I think he, he, he's doing this relatively unconsciously because he can't conceive of a world where he has to change assumptions. And if you let people strip all of the wiring out of psychology, like if you let it just become something that lets us, like I'm talking about in that third and fourth part, play with people's behavior and treat
一种超越时间的深奥精神工程，通过断章取义地引用哲学家来证明。当你这样做时，你并没有真正成为什么。你必须迎合所有这些人。你迎合他们的方式是告诉他们，历史是一种秘密代码，以一种听起来很聪明的方式验证了他们所有的假设。但你不能，而且你是唯一一个看到它的人，他们可以在你的帮助下看到它。我不认为彼得森在撒谎。我的意思是，我认为他是在相对无意识地做这件事，因为他无法想象一个他必须改变假设的世界。如果你让人们剥离心理学的所有内在联系，就像你让它变成某种让我们——就像我在第三和第四部分谈到的那样——玩弄人们的行为并对待
psychology like it's this tool to reprogram them. Like people are fundamentally robots that just respond to stimuli and that's it. Like if you do that, you've taken the human element out of psychology completely other than numbers. And that's terrifying because we've done that to other disciplines. You know, I really wanted to go into economics. And then I kept realizing that like nobody who was writing these books about economics, like knew much about it. They knew how to manipulate markets as they currently exist to make people's portfolios go up, but they didn't have any understanding or greater contextual knowledge about like the history of money or what value was, which is a huge question I'm not going to get into, you know, but I saw all these other people who were really
心理学，把它当作一种重新编程他们的工具。就像人们本质上是只对刺激做出反应的机器人，仅此而已。如果你这样做，你就完全剥离了心理学中的人文因素，只剩下数字。这很可怕，因为我们对其他学科也做了同样的事情。你知道，我真的很想研究经济学。然后我不断意识到，那些写经济学书籍的人，并没有多少了解。他们知道如何操纵现有的市场来让人们的投资组合上涨，但他们对货币的历史或什么是价值没有任何理解或更广泛的背景知识，这是一个巨大的问题，我不会深入探讨，你知道，但我看到所有其他真正
interesting, who were told, we'll go get a PhD and then we'll listen to you. And then they went and they said like, maybe the problem with a post Keynesian economic system is that it can't value non quantifiable assets, which means that, you know, we're not taking care of the things that create value in the first place, like nature and family and people and the long term health of a society, because there isn't a way to reduce them to a number. And a lot of those guys went and they got PhDs and they wrote these papers. And the system still didn't take them seriously because it can't. And what happened to the economic profession? I mean, what was the study that they did where like 85% of working economists
有趣的人，他们被告知，去拿个博士学位，然后我们会听你的。然后他们去了，他们说，也许后凯恩斯主义经济体系的问题在于它无法评估不可量化的资产，这意味着，你知道，我们没有照顾那些首先创造价值的事物，比如自然、家庭、人和社会的长期健康，因为没有办法把它们简化为一个数字。那些人中的许多人去拿了博士学位，写了这些论文。但系统仍然没有认真对待他们，因为它做不到。经济学界发生了什么？我的意思是，他们做的那个研究是什么，大约85%的在职经济学家
couldn't even attempt, partially attempt. And then like almost none of them but like 5% even attempt it partially attempt and then like almost none of them but like 5% even got it right the process of how money is created of what it is that a bank hits a keyboard and it's lent into existence at debt like that the bank doesn't have a million dollars when they give you a loan for a million dollars they have permission to create a million dollars from nothing by asking it back from you. And when you took the leading economists from the Ivy League schools, this study is more than 10 years old. And you ask them, what is money? They couldn't tell you.
甚至无法尝试，部分尝试。然后几乎没有人，只有5%的人甚至尝试了部分尝试，然后几乎没有人，只有5%的人甚至做对了货币创造的过程，即银行敲击键盘，它就以债务的形式借贷存在——银行在给你一百万美元贷款时并没有一百万美元，他们有权通过向你索回它来凭空创造一百万美元。当你从常春藤盟校挑选顶尖经济学家时，这项研究已经有10多年了。你问他们，什么是钱？他们回答不上来。
That's happening to psychology, but with people, but with self. And that's scary. That's, that's weird. Right. Um, and I think, but academic psychology, they at least know the context of these arguments and like the history of it and the way that these YouTube influencers like don't even begin to try and understand it's irrelevant to them. Um, and it's no like mistake or it's no like coincidence that they're all going to end up with this like um spiritualism basically and um philosophy because people think the philosophy is smart yet it was people wrestling with questions that aren't the one we're wrestling with now but you need to make history this like projection you need to project into history that it's this um you know huge uh journey to get to where you are to make your point uniquely relevant and when you do that um what you what you're you're
这正在心理学界发生，但针对的是人，针对的是自我。这很可怕。这很奇怪。对。嗯，我认为，但学术心理学，他们至少知道这些论点的背景，以及它的历史，而这些YouTube网红甚至根本不去尝试理解，这对他们来说无关紧要。嗯，他们最终都会走向这种基本上是唯灵论和哲学，这并非巧合，因为人们认为哲学很聪明，但它其实是人们在与我们现在所面对的问题不同的问题中挣扎，但你需要把历史变成这种投射，你需要投射到历史中，认为这是一场巨大的旅程，才到达你现在的位置，从而使你的观点具有独特的意义，当你这样做时，嗯，你所要做的
always going to end up with something like aristotle because aristotle's saying that the reason that you have the thought is that the form of the thing, like the idea, the knowledge itself is out there in the universe. And it is, you are resonating with it when you were having that thought. It's not that you were taking in information and then creating something in your brain. It's that you have a divine connection to knowledge, a divine connection to the proof, to the truth. And like Aristotle didn't think that you had ideas and the way that Descartes did. He thought that ideas had you. So when you're an archetypal psychologist who is essentially possessed by the ideas that you're talking about, and of course you're going to be coming back to
最终总是会得到像亚里士多德那样的东西，因为亚里士多德说，你之所以有这种想法，是因为事物的形式，即思想、知识本身就在宇宙中。当你产生那个想法时，你是在与它产生共鸣。并不是你在吸收信息，然后在你的大脑中创造了什么。而是你与知识有着神圣的联系，与证明、与真理有着神圣的联系。就像亚里士多德并不认为你拥有思想，就像笛卡尔那样。他认为思想拥有你。所以当你是一个原型心理学家，本质上被你所谈论的思想所占据时，当然你会回到
how something like that is right. But when you can't admit that, you're going to get just flailing around trying to solve an emotional problem intellectually by using all of this like logical rubrics and like crazy Rube Goldberg machines of thought to try and build some way to prove that the thing that you need to believe is empirical. It's not just that you need to believe it because it justifies who you are and what you want to do. It's that it is handed down by God. And that is something that is a release valve for self and this decaying relationship between self and world that psychotherapy isn't really holding, that society has as an inevitability if you don't build a better therapy. Like if you continue to say CBT and ABA and ultra medical and ultra whatever, maybe they still come to you.
像那样的事情是如何正确的。但当你不能承认这一点时，你就会变得只是在胡乱挣扎，试图通过使用所有这些逻辑准则和疯狂的鲁布·戈德堡式的思维机器，在智力上解决一个情感问题，试图建立某种方式来证明你需要相信的东西是经验性的。不仅仅是因为你需要相信它，因为它证明了你是谁以及你想做什么。而是因为它是由上帝传下来的。这是一种自我的释放阀，也是心理治疗无法真正维持的自我与世界之间这种衰退的关系，如果你不建立更好的治疗方法，社会必然会面临这种情况。就像如果你继续说CBT（认知行为疗法）和ABA（应用行为分析）以及超医学和超什么的，也许他们仍然会来找你。
Maybe they still think that what you're doing is helpful. Maybe they still, maybe you still make a lot of money. You know, I think even those things are going to start to be in danger, but maybe that still make a lot of money you know i think even those things are going to start to be in danger but maybe that still happens but where the soul goes you know where the trauma and the intuition and the nightmares of our culture goes is onto youtube So do better. Like psychotherapy, please do better. And that's as much as I'll say about philosophy. And those are all the other notes that I had for this series. Thanks. And we'll get back to the regular normal stuff real soon. We got an interview with Jeffrey Seiler coming up. He's a singer songwriter out of Austin. Really nice guy. Um,
也许他们仍然认为你所做的是有帮助的。也许他们仍然，也许你仍然赚了很多钱。你知道，我认为即使是这些事情也开始变得危险了，但也许这仍然会发生，但灵魂去向何处，你知道，我们文化的创伤、直觉和噩梦去向何处，是在YouTube上。所以做得更好吧。像心理治疗，请做得更好。关于哲学我就说这么多。这些是我为这个系列准备的所有其他笔记。谢谢。我们很快就会回到正常的常规内容。我们即将采访杰弗里·塞勒（Jeffrey Seiler）。他是奥斯汀的一位创作歌手。非常好的人。嗯，
this series is over. I hope you enjoyed it. We're getting back to normal things, uh, and we'll not probably go into this, uh, far in the woods on some weird for, for a while. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这个系列结束了。希望你喜欢它。我们要回到正常的事情上了，嗯，我们可能暂时不会再深入探讨这些奇怪的东西了。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。